Ferrari drivers design the hardest F1
track what's the hardest ever turn one
turn one Shanghai okay it's a really
really long corner like that where do we
go just Corners s of susuka like that
like that Monaco you go straight like
the very tight corner and then the dou
right before the tun boom boom then I
will go Barcelona then three that's
actually pretty nice Singapore T one3
okay that looks like a good truck long
straight yeah Asar she can yeah
yes oh my God we are going for a whole
new track now here like that and then
I'll invent something let's do something
fast now let's go triple ride of
Austin we need to finish it off baring
Turn 1 2 three I like yes that's it it's
actually a pretty nice truck it's a
combination of very high speeed Corners
with the slowest corners of the calendar
if you mess up one corner then that
means you mess up all the corners after
that it's also a truck that would be
extremely tough on tires yeah left tires
are two laps